[Musique]
bienvenue au restaurant Les Quatre
Saisons à Versailles mais c'est sa
comédie sur les chefs gérant des
restaurants alors aujourd'hui on va vous
parler des ris de veau c'est des coeurs
de veau pour aller
forestière champignon pomme de terre et
quelques feuilles de herbes
[Musique]
il y a une petite astuce à retenir sur
les ris de veau et qui sont des ris de
veau c'est surtout les démarrer à l'eau
tiède et avec avec ça on met un tout
petit peu de gros sel et aussi pendant
le faire revenir quand on voit le faire
revenir dans les poils il faut aller
dans
une cuillère la piller pour enlever tout
ce qui a de l'eau en tailleur pour que
ça soit bien caramélisé les ris de veau
et voilà
[Musique]